et de madame fillion madame bloc
d'esprit êtes vous avant ce débat sera
concentrée
sérieux comme d'habitude place tout de
suite aux candidats
bonsoir françois fillon conforama ajouté
soyez les bienvenus
depuis des mois et des mois je suis
l'objet d'une campagne absolument
ignominieuse qui a commencé par mme
accusé d'avoir financé sur fonds publics
a bordeaux une gigantesque mosquée qui
n'existe pas ensuite j'ai été rebaptisé
si je peux utiliser ce mot d'alain juppé
grand mufti bordeaux part il faudrait
pas que la dernière semaine on
redevienne la droite la plus bête du
monde et la dernière campagne c'est tout
simplement une accusation de salafisme
et de
antisémitisme ou sous-entendre voilà et
c'est quoi absolument pas laissez-moi
terminée absolument pas laissez-moi
terminer
cette compagne m'a fait beaucoup de mal
on voit très bien qu'il en colère parce
qu'au fond pendant des mois et des mois
il n'a pas réagi aux attaques très
violentes de sarkozy et de son clan qui
finalement ils ont fait beaucoup de mal
l'histoire de dalé juppé le salafiste
qui ne la connaît pas c'est une
appellation qui est assez éloignée
manifestement des accusations de
catholicisme réactionnaires qui pèsent
sur moi depuis quelques jours quand je
me fais traiter d' homophobes tous les
matins je n'ai pas entendu non plus
prendre la parole pour assurer ma
défense voilà chacun est grand et
s'occupe de ses affaires il était
confronté là à quelqu'un qui a pris une
avance énorme
voilà au premier tour ce qui est a
priori dans toute l'histoire politique
un handicap qui ne ce qui ne se remonte
pas pour que les ministres le président
de la république a fortiori ne doivent
pas être mis en examen ne doive doivent
avoir une attitude exemplaire si on
comprend bien ce qu'on a en tête c'est
que j'ai été condamné non parce que
c'était parce qu'il est abandonné mais
je veux aborder cette question de façon
très claire non c'était plutôt la reille
javi tueur on va déjà posé la question
voilà j'ai assuré j'ai payé
j'ai demandé aux français ce qu'ils en
pensaient ils ont renouvelé leur
confiance à plusieurs reprises par un
regard à l'égard de d'alain juppé où il
y avait une attente qui est une attente
de prises de position relativement forte
et avait pour lui un double enjeu non
seulement on faire en sorte que les
électeurs qui avaient voté à gauche les
idées de la gauche avait voté pour lui
mais pas uniquement pour lui mais
également pour faire en sorte que
nicolas sarkozy ne soit pas présent
deuxième jour continuent de voter vous
voulez dire que ce soir ya eu un appel à
des électeurs de gauche pour aller voter
dimanche
françois pour que là aussi clarifier un
point je le dis sans agressivité
j'espère qu'il ne prendra pas ainsi j'ai
cru comprendre que dans la fonction
publique il voulait passer aux 39 heures
dès 2017 et avec un salaire
correspondant à 37 heures ce n'est pas
juste on ne peut pas demander à des
fonctionnaires de travailler plus pour
gagner bois lassé de faire un point
fondamental parce que ça veut dire en
fait qu'alain juppé ne veut pas vraiment
changer les choses ce soir alain juppé
était sans doute un petit peu en deçà de
la main comme s'il avait commencé
peut-être à intégrer l'idée sa défaite
aimer la france et les français c'est la
clé de la réussite alors dimanche
j'invite tous les français qui voudront
participer à cette primaire à être les
acteurs de cette force qui avance